just finished a fantastic train day with
a bunch of property investors that's
been a good day guys yeah it's been good
very good this guy's in his 60s done 100
million he's absolutely killing in
property is that right now that's it
these guys as well amazing what's
happening how's the day before what a
fantastic day it was today oh my dear
brother oh you're a friend oh wow thank
you so much
these guys were how long you been
looking forward to presenting with you
how long have you been in property maybe
35 years 35 years and you're in your 70s
76 years old my dear brother he's going
to be the oldest winners on the
wednesday so motivated to come to see
samuel lee's everyone should come and
see samuel lee i appreciate you so much
i appreciate you so much john thank you
so much you guys as well doing do it
kicking butt such a pleasure sally as
well sally how's your how's your first
deal going
oh yeah it's it's going great but i want
to you know i want to grow i want to
multiply you're in the right place
you're in the right place well done so
you want to get in this environment come
on down it's free